hi
sie hat mich voll meine Videos von vor
sechs Jahren mit diesem ganzen
kann ich machen das Umfeld wenn ich hier
drauf schlage wo wir allerdings gerade
schon bei Themen von vor 6 Jahren sind
meine Damen und Herren das heutige Video
handelt von snapchat eine App die in
Deutschland irgendwie voller Bekanntheit
verloren hat in Amerika und anderen
Ländern außerhalb von Deutschland
allerdings extrem gestiegen ist im Hype
von daher dachte ich mir ey wie wär's
denn weil ich noch einen Account habe
auf snapchat mit 500.000 verloren weil
ich da früher sehr sehr aktiv war wie
wäre es denn wenn ich jetzt meinen
snapchat Account mal komplett öffentlich
stellen würde so dass jeder
mir ein snap senden kann
das konnten bisher nur Freunde von mir
ich habe sowieso extra eine Kerze
angezündet hier vorne ich habe auf jeden
Fall gerade dieses Video hier für meine
Instagram Story aufgenommen euer
lieblings-youtuber des Vertrauens hatte
die glorreiche Idee für ein
YouTube-Video seinen snapchat Account
komplett öffentlich zu stellen wenn du
also snapchat hast und mir schon immer
irgendwas sagen wolltest dann schick mir
jetzt einen snap wenn du mein neues
Youtube Video hier kommen willst und
dieses Video lade ich jetzt gerade in
meine Instagram Story hoch ein paar
Sekunden
selbst okay es geht los von daher würde
ich sagen wenn ich euch einfach mal hier
ein Screen recording von meinem snapchat
gerade ein
die Kerze ganz allein
so wir schauen uns mal was selbst
bekommen also mir wurde auf jeden Fall
schon ein bisschen was geschickt die
Story ist jetzt natürlich erst seit ein
paar Sekunden online allerdings schauen
wir erstmal der Juri hier schick mir
Nelly schickt mir ein Nokia
Handy von ihrem
Hund machen wir weiter mit Philipp der
mir alles klar Grüße aus Italien
und sie macht
26 das
Jason schickt mir mich
danke Bro als nächstes machen wir immer
weiter mit Felix
ich hasse euch so doll ne Atem schickt
mir das erste Video für heute und zwar
lass mal Durak zocken auf Ehre Lauch
deshalb war noch nichts Nettes dabei wir
dürfen allerdings nicht verzweifeln in
die kommen tatsächlich die ganze Zeit
neues Snaps noch an von daher machen
weiter mit Lina schwarzer Screen
schwarzer Screen schwarzer Screen
schwarzer Screen leon hat mir ein snap
geschickt in dem er mir den
soll ich einfach meinen Kanal vielleicht
löschen Jantje schick mir einen snap mit
nach sechs Wochen Spanien mit zehn
Pferden drei Tage LKW fahren endlich
wieder daheim
wow so eine Person würde ich auf
snapchat entfernen weil das ist 100%ig
wie steht ihr zu uns Snaps schickt ihr
selber auch welche ich bin total Doppel
moralisch was ist eigentlich ich hasse
es eigentlich komplett durch ich mache
selber manchmal weil so witzige Sachen
Karneval wenn der irgendwer kommt oder
so Filme
hallo du hi
ich antworte übrigens heute nicht ich
werde mir das jetzt erstmal nur
anschauen und mal gucken wenn ihr wollt
dass ich noch ein neues Video hier zu
machen wie ich euch dann antworte auf
snapchat dann schreibst du gerne unten
in die Kommentare Rebecca schickt mir
ein snap und sagt ich lerne Englisch
hat keiner gefragt
Erik schickt mir ein snap war wild mit
dir spielen zu dürfen oh
lol was ist mit Eric kannst du auch was
sagen
hallo also so langsam komme ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht mehr so richtig hinterher
hier mit den Snaps aber gut wir öffnen
jetzt mal den von Leo Caro luca du bist
mega sympathisch aber nichts du bist
toll oh das ist lieb dass das erste Mal
dass sie was Nettes kam
hey Laser
ich habe gerade mal rumgeschnitten
lassen ne auch wenn ich jetzt
chillig bro
ich wusste dass es keine gute Idee
schickt mir ein Video nehmen Sie
luca du stinkst ah du stinkst natürlich
der einzige Becher den Luca benutzen
dürfte Prinzessinnen welche
er hat einen Bild von dir gesehen und
wäscht sich jetzt die Augen ey
wir können es auch einfach sein lassen
mit mit meinen YouTube-Videos fangen wir
jetzt einfach mal oben an mit denen die
mir jetzt hier als letztes was geschickt
haben und zwar Finja i love hot Dance ey
Luca was geht alles was Beine hat außer
Stühle und Tische die schickt mir hier
ein süßes selfie mit ihrem Teddybären
noch eins wundervoll
aber egal machen wir weiter mit dem
nächsten snap von Jan Knoblauch
okay
chillig
chillig bro
chillig chillig natürlich
machen wir mal hier unten so ein
bisschen weiter Silja das ist boah die
Brille ist nice
wo die hätte ich echt gern Cars bester
Film was ist war okay was ist eure
Meinung nach der beste Animationsfilm
schreibt mir in die Kommentare
ich liebe diesen Wald von vor 6 7 Jahren
so Youtube mäßig auf die Chats gehe ich
jetzt nicht drauf weil das ist ein
bisschen langweilig glaube ich fürs
Video dann einfach nur Text ist aber wir
können ja noch mal ein Video Öffnen von
Marie die zu viert gerade im Bettchen
chillen und das chilliges Bild ist und
das auch und das auch und das auch
Menschen
Fans von dir würde ich mal sagen ja
you
okay okay wir machen jetzt ganz schnell
noch mal ein paar Snaps hintereinander
würde ich sagen komm schick mir der Fall
ist genauso dünn wie du chillig Brot
Chan schick mir eine Katze die mit dem
Telefon telefoniert sehr gut Lennart
schickt mir halt sie durch mein
eingeschissener Pavian sehr wild Bruder
Anna hallo laserlaka stabil äh Anna
schickt mir einen da bin ich auf falsche
geklickt Anna schick mir ein snap wie
sie einfach nur guckt Valentin schick
mir ein Bild mit seit wann
Nikita
Julia schickt mir ein snap
Henning schickt mir ein Video mal
schauen was er sagt hey Luca findet
deine Wohnung richtig
korrekt Bro danke also Ideen nehme ich
tatsächlich von Instagram äh ich kriege
auf meiner explore page unfassbar viel
so architekturkrams immer vorgeschlagen
und dann speicher ich mir das einfach ab
und er merkt man das so ein bisschen und
sonst ist auch vieles tatsächlich meine
Mutter keine Ahnung davon hier das ist
ich bin gerade in Köln die Lampe da weiß
ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz
davon halten soll
und was ich auch nicht so ganz normal
weiß ist schwarze Decke
ja nicht so ganz einverstanden mit aber
ist halt Schluck drin
sieht ich liebe es das Regal
das ist so wild damit dem Schachspiel da
was anderes geschenkt hat boah mit der
Backsteine brutal Forster
allerdings würde ich an der Stelle das
heutige Video jetzt auch beenden meine
wenn es euch gefallen hat dass ich mein
snapchat Mal öffentlich gemacht habe
dann lass doch gern einen Daumen hoch
unter dem Video hier da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke um
weitere Videos nichts verpasst ich würde
sagen komm wir machen noch fünf letzte
Snaps ganz schnell hintereinander nach
ganz oben die fünf letzten snapst du mir
geschickt wurden Paul du bist hässlich
korrekt Bruder lila bin ich im Video ja
bist du Luca Kästchen ah chillig Brot
chillig Brot und Anna ich liebe dich
luca ich liebe dich auch Anna und dann
nehmen wir noch äh ich mit rein
sag mal Regen rückwärts
haut rein macht's gut